The funniest part of my job
on a day when JB Smoove is coming in,
is inevitably someone,
today it was Aaron Bleyaert,
sitting right over there,
texting to try and get a
reservation at a fast food chain.
(audience laughs)
I love that you walked
in, Bley, and you're like,
"Here's some possible notes
of what you could talk
about with JB Smoove."
And I always, there is no more
ridiculous thing in the world
than for someone to
spend time writing down
things I might talk to JB about,
because I never have any idea
what we're gonna talk about.
I never have, you can't plan any of that.
You shouldn't plan any of that.
I never know what's gonna
happen and it just happens.
I don't know about you guys,
but I don't know, some,
talking to JB, there's a,
a moment or two where my, where my mind
wandered just a little bit, I think,
when he was talking about
some of the crazier stuff he wanted to do.
What were you thinking about?
I was thinking about EVs.
That's my term for-
I was too. That's weird.
Yeah, I was thinking
about electric vehicles.
That's cool.
Yeah, just because I
keep thinking, you know,
it used to be kind of weird.
This person has an electric vehicle.
Isn't that kind of strange?
But now EVs are everywhere.
And you know who's killing it with EVs?
Who?
One guess?
Yeah. One guess.
Chevy.
Yes. Chevy.
That was very natural.
Man, incredible. Yeah.
Chevy's killing it with EVs.
Yeah.
They've got one for everybody.
Anyway, I was thinking about
all the different types
of Chevys they have.
Chevy EVs. And you can buy
the Bolt EV or the Bolt EUV.
Wow.
Reserve the Blazer EV or the Silverado EV.
Yeah. That's your favorite.
[Conan] I love the Silverado
just 'cause of the name.
Yeah.
Yeah. I just walked into
a bar, and you're a lady
sitting at the bar, and you
saw me pull up in a truck.
Ask me what kind of truck I drive.
Hey, what kind of truck do you drive?
Silverado.
And I leave.
[Conan] You leave.
Yeah.
But I'm still here.
Not because you have
anything against Silverado,
but because you think that I
have something wrong with my-
It's because you said
it really weird. Yeah.
Yeah. No, Silverado EV. And learn more
about the Equinox EV
while staying tuned for
more info on Chevy's vision
for an electronic future.
Electric.
What's it?
It's an electric future.
Oh. And I said that you
would screw up the card.
Do we get the check if
I keep f@*#ing around?
We lost the check minutes ago.
We have to pay Chevy.
Yeah. We owe them.
No one has ever paid
us for any of our ads.
(everyone laughs)
To learn more about the Chevy EV lineup,
head to chevrolet.com/conan. Yeah.